PELES OU
YOU'RE LOOKI PICTURES
RIGHT NOW OUOF BOSTON WHERE ITO
YEAH.THAT SNOW IS SIDS.L.
WE WANT TOR MAULDI
S E BIG PICTURE FOR .
>> YEAH.Y, IS
E GROUND ZER SORTS.
RADAR  WELLD HERE ACROHE
ALYOU FACTOR IN THE , IT'S D,
COLDER OUTSIDE.
THE WIND IS GOIN B
THE SNOLES
UP BAUSE THAT'GOTOITIONSUCKET,DO
EASTERN MASSACHUSETTS THATS HIGO
FROM THE CAROL
MILLIONERZAHI
WARNING.YOU CASEE HOEA
FRO NORTH.O THE ROLINANG TO SE T
WE'RE NOT GOIN
MS IM DEA
WITHS.. S GO TW
LEBOUTCHIGTHEY'RPET UP
VEHY
DECLARED A STA
HE' THE
, BUT WITH
ET'S HEAD OVER
ARE I SAID BEFN THBO WERE INTEEU
IT THERE?teBOS, IT'
GETTG
STT HERE
Y MENTION,
NSE.G YS.
THISS OU4- OR L SNOW.G TO
NOTAD PLOWING'S MADE BYNO AND
ACCULA HERE.I GOT TO THE IT.RY
SIDETHIS IS BUDU
SNING A DRIVEWAY INTO A
HOTEL
IS ALMOST NDHI AROLINAVISIBILITE
WHAT WE'RE TOLBYY
OFFICIALS IS ESPECLL
NG AN TO THE
CIOPLE A EOA. HASD FR THE
K NG
THEYE E DOO
SEEIT'S HARR ME
TOND HERE AND
, EVEN MY SPEECH IS
AFFECTED WHEN GE  BURST AT CETIS
LI AVENUE.
ROUTE 40 MAIN E , WE W
TOLD BY A CITY OFFICIAT
BEEN SHUT DOWN DUIN AGAIN, HIGH
ACCUMULATIONS OF SW, HEAVY
NDING THE R FROM INL
HIGH TIDE WA
, FLOODING FROM THAT
HI TE IS AFFECTING THE MAIARTERT
US HERE, ALE OIOPEOPLE WALKING A
A.
WE HEAR THE WIND HOWLING A
YOU'IN